you just did a zombie movie uh not long
ago you did a zombie movie
and uh i was wondering we had the cast
of the walking dead here a couple days
ago
and i was asking them what they would do
in a zombie apocalypse and it seems to
be something that a lot of us these days
think about because zombies have become
so popular
did you think about that when you're
shooting that movie what you would do in
a zombie apocalypse
um no i didn't but
okay next question uh
just kidding i thought i've thought
about it
a lot and um i was telling someone the
other day that
um i i'm always prepared in any kind of
apocalypse situation not just
zombies but i have like a whole thing
like i sleep with a
dagger at by my side and don't
you really what do you mean you have a
dagger where where's the dagger it's not
in the bed it's my nightstand and
every week i do a shanking uh drill
where i i'm asleep you're asleep
i imagine like a zombie or a murderer
um or whoever is coming to get me right
and
and then i like have a move where i like
quickly slide it under the blanket and
then i just shank
up whoever's hovering over me about to
kill me
that seems incredibly dangerous you know
what if
uh someone's staying over at the house
what if your boyfriend's leaning over
for a kiss
and you've got that motion you enter
my room at your own risk okay all there
is
you always have you have weapons nearby
at all times i have
a dagger i also like to surround myself
with
people with skills that could be useful
um that's something i always keep in
mind with like friends or
boyfriends or whatever um you want them
to have useful skills if there's an
apocalypse of some kind
like what for example like my current
boyfriend
uh when we first started dating i gave
him helicopter lessons
flying lessons for his birthday he never
showed an interest in flying but i just
gave him
to him in case like the world has gone
to [ __ ]
and we need to fly away so
i was like i need to be with someone
that can operate
a helicopter first of all why don't you
take the helicopter last night because
i'm in charge of weapons and ammo
and then i would steal the helicopter
and then he would he would take it
so first of all you don't have a health
so you've got to get to a helicopter oh
yeah and you've got to hope the keys are
in it
and steal he good enough then you can't
in a day learn to fly a helicopter yeah
you can
and it's not even that much money well
no you cannot i'm telling you you cannot
learn
he's good at flying a helicopter after a
day he did it because he was scared
but um but i'll just get someone to do
it
i just have to have someone that knows
how to fly
i'll take lessons i would take it okay
i'll learn how to fly
okay you know that you know you can
always count on me all right
jesus what was that look about i just
offered to save your life by flying and
you did it
away i felt terrible now no i
marry me
[Applause]